bundestags generaldebatte am mittwoch
und eine flehende bundeskanzlerin und
geradezu anfleht vor weihnachten bevor
man oma und opa großeltern und ältere
menschen sieht eine woche der kontakt
reduzierung zu ermöglichen dann sollten
wir vielleicht doch noch mal nachdenken
ob wir nicht irgendeinen weg finden die
ferien nicht erst am 19
beginnt zu lassen sondern vielleicht
schon am 16 was wird man dann im
rückblick auf eine jahrhunderte eines
mal sagen wenn wir nicht in der lage
waren für diese drei tage noch
irgendeine lösung zu finden
und das läuft ja sein es mag sein dass
die auslegung der schließlich das
falsche ist dann muss es der digital
unterricht oder sonstwas seit ich weiß
es nicht das ist auch nicht meine
kompetenz da will ich mich einmischen
ich will immer sagen denn wir jetzt vor
weihnachten zu viele kontakte haben und
anschließend es das letzte weihnachten
mit den großeltern war dann werden wir
etwas versäumt haben das sollten wir
nicht tun
im gespräch mit bild äußert sich nun
auch spd arbeitsminister hubertus heil
zu dieser ansprache
man muss nicht jede formulierung immer
mögen aber in der sache hat die
kanzlerin absolut recht das ist eine
erschreckende entwicklung in einzelnen
regionen deutschlands leben wir dass
krankenhäuser überfordert sind das
menschen verlegt werden müssen und dass
die infektion nicht mehr unter kontrolle
sind dass wir keine nachverfolgung haben
und deshalb ist das das richtige signal
der bundeskanzlerin gewesen jetzt zu
sagen lasst uns versuchen mit
gemeinsamer neuer kraftanstrengung das
hinzukriegen
und es ist ja auch licht am ende des
tunnels wir haben die chance im nächsten
jahren impfstoff zu bekommen und damit
auch gut durch diese krise zu kommen
aber jetzt ist das notwendig auch zum
geplanten knallhart lockdown hat der
minister eine klare meinung wir müssen
feststellen dass die bisherigen
maßnahmen nicht ausreichen um das
infektionsgeschehen im griff zu behalten
wir erleben dass krankenhäuser
überlastet sind das leider viel zu viele
menschen mit 19 oder anrufe 19
versterben deshalb ist es notwendig dass
wir uns stärker am ende des jahres
einschränken
aber es vor allem notwendig dass viele
bürgerinnen und bürger sich dann an die
regeln auch halten um die gesundheit
ihrer nachbarn ihre angehörigen
auch zu schützen das ist jetzt notwendig
und so feiert hubertus heil das
weihnachtsfest in corona ja ja wir
werden uns im engsten familienkreis
versammeln also meine frau und meine
beiden kinder werden kochen werden das
ruhig angehen lassen und uns versuchen
miteinander ist schön zu machen viel
laufen fällt natürlich aus dieses jahr
aber persönliche weihnachten wird geben
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren